our second speaker in our second topic
is about security Niels Provos
is a distinguished engineer at Google
focused on security and privacy now for
context there are only about 50
distinguished engineers inside all of
Google now and according to his
Wikipedia page in his spare time he's
turned steel into swords you know and
security is different than many other
features it's an opportunity for us to
work with you to create the best
possible security environment for you
your customers and with GCP we have a
great opportunity to put more and more
of the tools that we use to manage our
security into your hands so that you can
manage your security as well so with
that I'm really delighted and honored to
bring up on stage Neal Provost
distinguished engineer from Google Neal
thank you for the introduction Greg good
morning everybody
as Greg said I'm a distinguished
engineer at Google I am responsible for
the security and privacy engineering
teams today I would like to pull back
the covers a little bit and share with
you a glimpse on how we pervasively
secure you your data your customers data
and your applications when you run on
top of Google's cloud platform however
let me set the stage a little bit first
at the reasoned and nigma conference in
San Francisco Rob Joyce the head of
NSA's tailored access operations made
the following statements on how advanced
adversaries managed to break into your
systems and networks now I understand
that most of you would like to spend
your time and focus on building a great
product and great new features for your
customers however your adversaries they
focus their time and energy on finding
weak spots in your systems that they can
exploit fortunately at Google I lead the
team of experts who build systems and
processes specifically designed to
thwart adversaries we do this by
anticipating them preventing them
detecting them disrupting them and
containing them and we will work with
you to make sure that we can meet your
requirements and that you can leverage
our security capabilities on top of the
platform so now I would like to give you
a little bit more insight in how we
think about security at Google and how
we have created the secure
infrastructure for ourself Google
security and privacy team consists of
over 500 people who continuously work to
protect our infrastructure and you when
you're running on top of TCP due to our
scale we end up seeing all kinds of bad
behavior across the internet phishing
emails malware websites Network attacks
and we also see all kinds of adversaries
ranging from all levels of
sophistication not just script kiddies
and cyber criminals but also
nation-state actors now at Google we are
not pursuing a hardshell perimeter model
instead we are
we focused on pervasive defense and
death this is similar to the immune
system analogy that also mentioned
yesterday there are two creep key
principles running pervasively to our
approach to security and their distrust
in transparency that means that we
design for trust throughout our stack
and we build in the transparency so that
you can verify for yourself and in fact
this talk is one of our steps in giving
you more transparency now I'll be
talking about Google's infrastructure in
the first part of the talk you know how
we think about security there and then
the second part of the talk I will
explain how that applies to you when you
run on top of TCP in order to facilitate
this discussion we have split our stack
into eight different layers and I'll be
walking from the bottom up you know
starting with the hardware to the boot
process all the way up to deployment
operations and usage and the hardware
layer we are fortunate enough that we
operate at such a skill that we can
build our own proprietary secure systems
that means that we have purpose-built
Hardware for computing storage
networking all the way through to full
data centers as you just heard Joe talk
about our ability to design and deploy
custom hardware means that we can
maintain provenance and establish trust
at the hardware level now on top of this
trusted hardware it's important that we
can also boot in a trusted way and to
accomplish that we have employed code
signing that allows us to verify the
BIOS the bootloader and the kernel and
that means that only the intended
software can run on Google's
infrastructure so now that we know that
our machines have booted in a known good
state it's also important that all of
our jobs communicate in an authenticated
and authorized fashion to accomplish
that we have built a triple graphic key
distribution system called laws that
allows us to establish cryptographic
identities for all jobs that run on our
infrastructure we know it ordered the
binaries that
so we can establish trust not only at
the operating system but also for the
apps that are running on it
now we referred a lot about virtual
machines and one of the properties we
really need there secure isolation at
Google we use KTM as our hypervisor
technology and we have significantly
invested to harden its security that
means that our security teams have found
fifteen of the last 21 publicly known
vulnerabilities in KVM that means that
we are the first to fix in the first
patch but of course we also contribute
our findings back to the community so
that everybody can benefit from a more
secure KVM technology and we continue on
working to make KVM even more secure to
get a secure operating system image on
our machines we have created a Google
curated image that we run throughout our
production infrastructure this is very
similar to the recommendation from the
NSA of having a secure baseline
we have also deployed a service that
alerts us of vulnerabilities and
third-party source code to further
protect our services now at the storage
layer it's really important that all
access to data is individually
authorized in tackled before we write
data to disk we chunk it and spread it
so that not all data ends up on the same
server we also encrypt data and metadata
individually and to protect these
encryption keys we have built a system
called key store that wraps them by
encrypting them further our storage
systems only store this rep key and
never the original cryptographic key
that would be required to decrypt the
data and that means that all access to
data requires interaction with key store
which gives us logging and auditing
capabilities similar for data and motion
we encrypted when the travels between
systems that we control we accomplish
fine-grained control over access with
our internal iam systems and they also
give us logging and auditing
capabilities
so now at this point we are running on
trusted hardware we know that the boot
process was trusted we trust our
operating system and we also have
provenance for Hardware boot and OS we
encrypt the data and we know that all
access is authenticated and authorized
now to secure our applications we are
pursuing multiple layered approaches one
of them is that we have built a binary
on configuration verification system
that means that for all applications we
know how they were built we know how
they were configured and we know how
they were deployed and for each of these
steps we know who was responsible for
them to put additional security into our
development process we require that all
code gets peer reviewed that means there
is a second pair of eyes that looks at
the code before it's being committed so
we can find bugs and security problems
very early on to help our teams create
more secure systems we also require a
security review before anything can
launch that means that we can put
security into our products right at the
design phase however you know even with
the best practices you still cannot
prevent all security problems and so we
have created a security scanning
technology that allows us to find many
of the common mistakes cross-site
scripting mixed content mix pinning you
know more strange attacks such as was
that a flash and we have also used this
as an example in where we can contribute
back to the community we have made our
firing range testbed open-source that is
if anybody else would like to develop
their own security technology anning
technology we already have a ready-made
app that they can test against so at
this point our applications are reviewed
they have been tested we believe they
don't have vulnerabilities data is
encrypted and access is authorized but
now it's time to expose these
applications to the dangerous web and
there are multiple different ways in
which we secure our applications there
first of all on the network we protect
the traffic with TLS to prevent man in
the middle attacks we have put
certificate pinning into our Chrome
browser so that we only trust the right
certificates
we have also deployed unfishable user
identity to our users with unfishable
hardware second factors and to protect
against network attacks we have built-in
DDoS protection some of you it might
effort recently about project shield
will be announced that we are extending
this DDoS protection to news and human
rights organizations as well as
selection monitoring sites thank you at
the operations level we have built
technology that allows us to patch and
monitor to Incident Response forensics
threat analysis and threat intelligence
and this is also another example we have
contributed back to the open source for
making some of our forensic tools
available such as grr or recall for
memory analytics now one of the sayings
that we have is the first user who is
going to be hitting your application is
likely going to be an app user so we
give our developers tools to be able to
do reputation checks on URLs and
binaries we have automated analysis of
traffic to find botnets that might be
engaging in spam and we also leverage
our global view on banners to build
threat intelligence on bad actors and
current attack vectors however to reduce
the overall attack surface that we face
and that our users face on the Internet
and that all of you face we created
project zero in 2014 it is a team
dedicated to finding zero day
vulnerabilities in critical internet
software you may have heard about the
heartbleed bug in open SSL also
mentioned that briefly yesterday or
about row hammer we're just reading
memory can lead to remote code execution
and most recently we announced the
widespread security vulnerability in G
Lib C so that means that we have a team
that finds you know critical security
problems that are very widely spread and
you know we had get the benefit of you
know knowing about these first so we can
fix our own infrastructure but we can
also work with the rest of the community
to make sure that we get the infinite
internet infrastructure you know fixed
in general as I mentioned in the
yes light you know writing secure
software is difficult and Google has
been one of the first companies to
create a vulnerability rewards program
will be asked researchers across the
world with helping find security bugs on
our products and just last year we paid
out over two million dollars to hundreds
of researchers who helped us build more
secure products so now let's switch over
to DCP I've just told you and I hope you
understand a little better about the
security capabilities that we have built
for ourselves you might wonder that's
great but you know how does that apply
to us and when we run on GCP these
security capabilities that I mentioned
to you is what enables our Google
developers to live you know the v3 cloud
experience the next cloud experience it
means that they can focus on building
you know amazing products and they do
not have to be security experts now we
understand that many of you are in a
spectrum on how you develop and manage
your applications and all of you are
going to be in different points in your
journey to this next version of cloud we
understand that you may have to manage
and segment segment your network to
create trust zones or that you need more
explicit control over the firewall of
the network parameter all of you need
logging and auditing capabilities and we
are really committed to help you meet
your goals wherever you are on your
journey to this next version of the
cloud and to accomplish that we are
increasingly making more of these
capabilities available to you and I will
be explaining to you a little bit how
that is going to look like so I
mentioned you know previously we had
eight layers and recognition of the need
that many of you need better control
over the network we have introduced a
network layer here so I mentioned to you
what it is that we do at the hardware
level or that is that we do for our boot
process and at the operating system
level you are actually benefiting of all
of these mechanisms already because GCP
is built on top of these many of you of
ultra compliance requirements and our
infrastructure is regularly audited by X
auditors for sock two and three iso
27001 pci DSS 3.0 and for Google compute
engine Google Cloud storage cloud sequel
and bigquery we are also covered under
the HIPAA BAA that means that you can
build on top of an infrastructure
foundation that is regularly audited and
certified for cloud at the storage level
all data is already encrypted by default
to give you even greater control on how
data is being stored at rest we have
made customer supplied encryption keys
available to you and we also give you
all that logging capabilities in the
future we plan on giving you even more
control with a key management system
that allows you to manage your own keys
you know generate them rotate them
suspend resume them delete them or
manage the important export of Secrets
yesterday you referred about our I am
system that we have not made available
to you which gives you explicit role
based access control and we will give
you additional capabilities later on in
the year now at the network layer many
of you require explicit control in fact
today there are already many ways in
which you can customize your network
such as with isolated IP groups private
IP addresses VPNs or inbound firewalls
we are working on extending and
expanding these features including
outbound firewalls when you run on
Google App Engine you already can
benefit from the security scanning
technology that I mentioned to hear
earlier with the cloud security scanner
we are working on creating more scanners
and on increasing the scanning
capability so it can also use it on GCE
and gke we also plan to give you the
ability to sign your binaries so you can
verify and enforce what gets to run as
part of your infrastructure we are also
thinking of giving you source code
security capabilities however that
requires that you first store your
source code with us so please check out
the Google cloud sauce repositories
for protecting your developers and users
we already give you the options of using
security keys which give you this you
know unfishable hardware second factor
many of you at the moment may be relying
on the sort of you know hard network
parameter that i've been talking about
earlier we also plan on giving you
detailed and sophisticated identity and
authorization tools that means that you
can write access policy not just based
on the user but also on the machine and
location you may have heard about the
beyond Corp model yesterday that sort of
goes in that direction when you leverage
Google's scale by using let's say the
HTTP load balancer you also benefit from
built-in DDoS protection to protect your
SSL and TLS certificates we have been
working for years on something that is
called certificate transparency that
essentially creates publicly verifiable
locks that give you provenance and Trust
for the certificates for your own
domains for operations you already
benefit essentially from all the
practices that we have for the
underlying infrastructure we'll be you
know regularly patch and upgrade however
for your own projects we are looking
into giving you an integrated view that
gives you an idea of the patch level and
vulnerabilities for your own deployments
and we're also thinking of ways of
adding some of our threat intelligence
into that view you already can benefit
from audit logging and stackdriver to
give you a better idea and detailed
records of what's going on with your
infrastructure and your data in the
future we plan on giving you strong
of--this is how it works I can factor
you know for for logging into your
projects but we are also investigating
additional app use signals that we might
be able to make available to you when
you develop your applications such as
URL and binary reputation so these are
just some of the security capabilities
that we will increasingly make available
to you to access and control you already
have the option for us to manage the
security on the platform
if you use for example google appengine
but we also plan on giving you the
ability to leverage an increasing array
of security features that you can manage
to your own requirements and to be clear
our goal here is to provide you the
control you need on the trusted and
transparent cloud so that you do not
have to become security experts but can
instead focus on innovation and creating
a great business thank you very much